what happens behind the scenes can mean
just as much as what happens on the ice
and NHL 17s all new franchise mode lets
you control it all each team has an
owner each of which comes complete with
their own unique personality and set of
goals that you will have to navigate
over the course of a season franchise
mode now gives you the capability to
manage your whole operations budget and
marketing plan as you work to complete
goals and keep ownership happy find the
sweet spot for ticket prices concessions
merchandise and even parking while keep
your franchise profitable and successful
as your fan base girls solely your
responsibilities so be smart with your
budgets upgrade facilities where needed
or set promotional days for key games
including free t-shirt promotions and
player bobblehead giveaways to keep fans
smiling your decisions carry over into
gameplay so putting a solid product on
the ice and making smart business
decisions behind the scenes both play a
major role in keeping your fans coming
back night in and night out if you're
looking to shake things up you may have
the option to relocate your franchise to
a new market if ownership approves
relocation choose from a list of select
cities and weigh options that include
stadium costs and city aided funding
while taking a close look at market size
and fanbase help zero in on the best fit
for your franchise once you've negotiate
the deal that works for you lock in your
location and dry the full creative
direction of your you team uniforms and
arena design whatever your game plan
might be initial 17's franchise mode
puts you in the center
all of the action and there's no better
feeling than seeing a successful team on
the ice a packed stadium full of fans on
their feet